how should a muslim respond to the
calamities that he or she faces
due
to what is written in his or her destiny
as i mentioned earlier
whenever any calamity befalls
and human being it is either a test
or it's a punishment
if it's a punishment like it's mentioned
surah
chapter number 11 verse number 2
turn the two cities upside down of
kameloot and showered brimstone of hard
layer upon layer that means it's a
punishment
so if it's a punishment
then that person
should seek forgiveness
and it should depend he should stop
doing that evil act
stop doing that thing
should promise not to do it again
if he can reverse it he should reverse
it
and seek for allah's forgiveness
if
it is
a test like allah says in surah baqarah
chapter number 2 verse number 155 that
surely
we will test you
with something of fear and hunger
or loss
in goods or lives
or toils of your fruit
and give glad tidings to the person
who patiently perseveres
and
further it's mentioned in surah baqarah
chapter 2 verse number 156
that
the other people who say
innalillahi were inna ilahi rajyoon that
from him we come and to him is our
return so this talks about the people of
the believer if anything calamity
befalls if he's at fault look into
himself
if he's done some sin he should
immediately repent and ask for
forgiveness if it is a test then he
should patiently persevere
and he should have suffered and says
for example if a person falls or if the
death takes place or a person gets sick
the right thing as the quran says
that from him we come into him is a
return
and
it's mentioned surah by chapter number
nine verse number 51
say
nothing can happen except with the
decree of allah subhanahu wa
for allah is our protector
and tell the believers that put the
trust in allah
it's further mentioned in surat kabun
chapter number 64 verse number 11 that
no calamity can befall us
except with the leave of allah
so let us have belief in allah allah is
the one who guides our heart
and it's mentioned in surah asumur
chapter 39 verse number 10
that the reward is that those who
patiently persevere will truly have a
reward
and
it's mentioned in surah baqarah chapter
number 2 verse number 153
that oh you believe
seek allah's help
with patience perseverance and prayer
for verily allah is with those who
patiently persevere
so
a person should patiently persevere and
this hadith
it's mentioned say muslim volume number
four hadith number seven one three eight
the beloved muslim said that strange are
the ways of a believer
if anything good happens to him he
thanks allah
and if any calamity be false he
patiently perseveres
and yet there's good for him in the
hereafter so whenever any calamity takes
place if he's at fault he should rectify
it otherwise he should patiently
persevere for allah says seek help of
allah with patience perseverance and
prayer overly
foreign